I was so impressed obviously with Gollum
and then with Caesar in the last movie
and now this movie how you're able to
really bring these guys to life you had
to you you studied because what's
different about this movie I love the
last one and what I really like with it
essentially about this movie if you're
taking it to the next level is that the
Apes can now talk ten years has gone by
so that's the last movie they can talk
now and because they can talk you had to
learn different ape vocalizations you
give me like an examples of like what
the different vocalizations might be I'm
just curious what it's like well yeah I
mean like a gorilla gorilla
if a gorillas saying I'm alright are you
alright that kind of they go anyway
alright interviews go this way I've
talked to some actors usually usually
leading men you know and then of course
the famous chimp ant hoot which which
you can both over go if you like is that
well they kind of go
[Applause]
I'm bleeding into my Andy do you want to
take a shot about to fling feces again
would it be like if if if Gollum wanted
to have a conversation with Caesar how
would that go well it would it would
probably go something like I can call
them on the funny
[Applause]
and then Gollum would join in and
Smeagol would go
when they're arguing over whether or not
I'm funny they sound like my parents
when I was growing up
you